bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine
football mon team moto noire raté le
coche dans le championnat excellence les
imans teint se sont inclinés dans les
dernières secondes contre l'équipe 2 de
versailles le résumé du match et a su
dans ce magazine vendée globe 2016 ils
ne sont plus que 2 illinois en course le
versaillais tanguy de lamotte a dû être
contraint à l'abandon large cap vert
suite un problème avec son mât au tour
sur ces derniers jours de compétition
dans cette émission
escrime un tournoi pour préparer les
jeux olympiques de 2024 était programmé
au gymnase maurice baquet de guyancourt
ce dimanche les futures stars de la
discipline était peut-être présente plus
d'informations à suivre
gros plan présent sur les principaux
résultats du week end
on commence ce magazine du sport évinois
part du football et le championnat
excellence montille retenus avaient
l'occasion de se relancer ce week-end
dans cette division les imans teint se
sont inclinés contre l'un des favoris de
la poule versailles 2 les
saint-quentinois ont concédé la défaite
sur leur pelouse 1 0 le montage est
signée à romain respini mauvaise
opération pour l'équipe de football de
montigny le bretonneux dans le
championnat excellence les verts se sont
inclinés à domicile sur une pelouse
détrempée contre l'équipe 2 de
versailles
après une première période ponctuée par
plusieurs occasions franches les saint
quentinois en lever le pied après la
pause et ont finalement craqué dans les
dernières minutes de la partie défaite 1
mam est en passe des choses qu'on a
réussi à mettre en place sur le terrain
maintenant
c'est sur un petit détail un coup prend
aux côtés d'un coup de karité
certainement un problème de marquage ça
dommage parce qu'on avait comme géo des
bonnes a bien travaillé à la fin du
match les saint quentinois sont sortis
très remontée au près de larbitre ce
dernier a décidé de ne pas accorder deux
penalties signés montrent un 1 but a
également été refusée en seconde période
après une poussette sur le gardien nous
rendons pas grand chose à dire c'est
comme ça il fallait qu au classement
montigny le bretonneux descend la 9e
place du championnat seulement 1 points
de l'avant-dernier guyancourt saint
quentin nous on vient de monter donc on
regarde avec beaucoup d'humilité on est
au milieu de tableau que la priorité
n'est entendu c'est de se maintenir
maintenant la poule est très homogène il
ya tous les matches ont accroché et on
sait qu'en faisant une petite sa série
de victoires ça peut aller très vite
dans un sens comme dans l'autre si c'est
une série de hbo fait malheureusement
donc nous on va rester ambitieux on va
essayer d'aller jouer les premières
places
et c'est un coup d'arrêt aujourd'hui
mais on va rebondir rapidement
on reste concentrés solidaires et les
efforts qu'on fait à l'entraînement ça
va finir par payer et être un petit peu
plus réalistes en attaque
montigny-le-bretonneux avant dernière
attaque du championnat avec 8 buts se
déplacera sur le teint de maurepas la
deuxième plus mauvaise défense de la
division ce dimanche 27 novembre à 15
heures au stade du bout des clous on
continue par du football et la coupe
gambardella on connaît désormais le
futur adversaire des clayes-sous-bois
pour la coupe de france des moins de 19
ans le tirage au sort a été effectué au
siège de la fédération française de
football mercredi dernier le club
yvelinois qui évolue en deuxième
division de district recevra les
normands de caen asptt à l'occasion de
ce 6e tour et que les sous bois avait
créé la sensation en reversant clichy
sur seine au tour précédent sur le score
de 3 buts à 1 avec cette qualification
les glissières sur le plus petit club
français encore en course dans l'épreuve
du ballon rond on passe au ballon ovale
nouvelle victoire pour versailles dans
le championnat honneur de division
honneur le genre de la cité royale
enregistré leur cinquième victoire de la
saison contre vitry 26 à 19 au stade de
porchefontaine sous une pluie battante
ce résultat est peut-être un tournant
dans la saison des versailles et cette
victoire leur permet de rester au
contact des deux premières places on
écoute le président du club olivier hahn
air neufs dont la conforte nos toiles
une place maintenant hier le mans pis
mais un bonus offensif
aucun écart pour la deuxième place de
deux points
maintenant aujourd'hui bagneux avec son
jeu deux ans son jeu très restrictif
pour le moment finit toujours est
parfois la course en tête
donc nous on regarde bien sûr devant
regarde plus derrière maintenant on les
matchs vont jouer les uns après les
autres
sachant que pour le moment on ne lui
jetons à la première place et on vit la
deuxième prochain match pour les
versailles et ce dimanche à 15 heures
sur le terrain de vincennes on joue
également ce week-end en fédérale 3 de
rugby tout va bien pour plaisir après
avoir remporté leur dernier match contre
caen 75 à 0
les plaisirs oies se sont imposés 45 à 0
contre ce qu une véritable démonstration
contre l'une des équipes les plus
faibles de la poule les joueurs de jean
me sont toujours deuxièmes du classement
à cinq points du leader
ris orangis on va à présent par les
voiles dans ce magazine ils ne sont plus
que 2 illinois sur le vendée globe 2016
exit tanguy la mode qui repart aux
sables d'olonne sans assistance le
verset eu un souci avec son mât pour les
deux autres rien à signaler laventure
continue retour sur ces derniers jours
de compétition pascal josèphe à pour le
montage 3 heavy nous avaient pris le
départ du vendée globe 2016 le 6
novembre dernier des sables d'olonne ils
ne sont plus que deux en course le
verset tanguy de lamotte qui vise une
place dans le top 10 sur ce tour du
monde en solitaire et sans escale et
contraint à l'abandon
le navigateur a cassé sa tête demain au
nord du cap vert après avoir tenté de
réparer les dégâts près de deux jours
les viennois dû se rendre à l'évidence
et a décidé d'abandonner ce mardi 15
novembre
donc j'ai pris la décision difficile
avec mon équipe de ne pas aller
affronter les mers du sud avec un mât
dans cet état là et risquent de s'ouvrir
et c'est beaucoup trop dangereux d'aller
dans ces endroits il reste encore vingt
mille milles de course et j'ai pas envie
de risquer le sur accident dont mon sens
marin
veut que je fasse demi tour vers les
sables d'olonne mais toujours dans
l'esprit du vendée globe c'est à dire
sans assistance sans escale mais en
solitaire je ramène mon bateau à bon
port
et c'est la meilleur moyen c'est le
meilleur moyen de boucler cette aventure
de son côté l'autre versailles et éric
bellion nos vies sur ce vendée globe est
positionné à la 22e place de la flotte
au pointage de 15 heures ce lundi 21
novembre après un peu plus de quinze
jours de course et moi j'ai envie d'un
peu de m'attarder sur ces moments
difficiles où aller dans mon poste de
veille
alors je vais encore me reposer un peu
elle est très à son tir et les mains
aussi sont marqués à mener le bateau
jusque là ça n'a pas été facile j'ai eu
des moments difficiles de fatigue de
cafard de moment où je pensais pas y
arriver et ça c'est très important d'en
parler parce que l'inconnu laventure la
différence
tout ça ça demande des sacrifices à
demande de l'effort ça demande un
engagement farouche ceux qui vous disent
que c'est du tout cuit ça marche tout
seul c'est les gens qui n'essaie pas
c'est les gens qui font que parler
non ça ne mange vraiment une
une volonté farouche vraiment farouche
le 3ème évinois louis burton est lui
aussi arrivé dans l'hémisphère sud après
quelques frayeurs au départ avec son
imoca bureau vallée le navigateur occupe
la 13ème place
tout va bien à bord j'espère que
vous amuser à suivre cette course elle
est passionnante à courir en tout cas
c'est là où je poste le plus clair de
mon temps quand on va bien à bord et qui
a pas besoin de les manoeuvrer donc à
l'abri de cette magnifique casquette
superbement préparé par l'équipe
le britannique alex thomson sur hugo
boss est pour l'instant en tête de la
flotte il devance sébastien josse et
armel le cléac'h le passage du cap de
bonne espérance est programmée pour la
fin de semaine
retour sur la terre ferme ils sont les
dignes héritiers des trois mousquetaires
ils participeront peut-être aux jeux
olympiques de paris si la candidature
est choisie par le cio
les meilleurs escrimeurs de la région
âgés de 11 à 14 ans se sont affrontés au
gymnase maurice baquet de guyancourt
baptisée horizon 2024 compétition fait
office de détection pour ces jeunes
patrick jacques de dixmude un point les
images regarde ce dimanche 20 novembre
duo quoi peut être accueillis au gymnase
maurice baquet les futures stars
françaises de l'escrim 70 jeunes âgés de
11 à 14 ans ont participé à ce tournoi
départemental baptisée horizon 2024 la
journée qualificative pour les
championnats nationaux avait également
pour but de détecter les pépites de la
discipline et de quelques personnes bien
prometteur c'est bien chez les filles
que chez les garçons et pas uniquement
dans le club de guyancourt sentiments et
à d'autres clubs du département qui
s'illustre au niveau national objectif
des organisateurs impulser un nouveau
souffle sur cette discipline en france
ce sport plus grand pourvoyeur de
médailles pour les tricolores aux jo
avec 118 médailles reste sur deux
olympiades mitigé avec seulement trois
médailles engrangées en huit ans et pas
forcément plus eu de redorer ses pouvoir
briller lors des grandes compétitions et
donc
pour ça se prépare et il faut détecter
le plus tôt possible les personnes
capables de loin ce dimanche matin
chaque participant a déjà à son actif
plus de trois ans d'expérience dans la
discipline espère continuer sa passion
au plus haut niveau
c'est un sport de rapidité et ça qui me
voulaient mais qu' on joue beaucoup avec
son adversaire lui que ce soit les
contrats les contraintes les touchent
jamais tout absolument tout la
concentration la patience et en même
temps il faut être vraiment très rapide
pour attaquer une passion qui pourrait
les emmener à combattre en 2024 au grand
palais à paris si la france est retenue
pour organiser les jeux un rêve à la
pointe de l'épée
on reste dans l'actualité des jeux
olympiques nous sommes dans la dernière
ligne droite pour les jo de 2024 la
france a présenté à ce mardi à 15
novembre à doha son dossier de
candidature devant le cio judokas double
médaille d'or teddy riner s'est entourée
par la délégation française s'est montré
confiant la sortie de ce premier grand
oral par est encore en course avec les
dossiers de budapest et de los angeles
si le projet de paris a validé 4city
villes ont été retenues dans le dossier
le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueillera
les épreuves de bmx et de cyclisme sur
piste le golf national recevra les
meilleurs joueurs de la planète
le château de versailles harmonisera le
pentathlon moderne et les épreuves
d'équitation
enfin il y aura du vtt sur la colline
d'elancourt l'attribution des jeux se
fera à lima au pérou en septembre 2010
est en passe maintenant notre rubrique
agenda
un combat qui ne faudra pas manquer si
vous êtes un fan de boxe le verrier roi
ahmed el moussaoui a 26 ans affrontera
l'espagnol ceferino rodriguez pour le
titre vacant de champion d'europe ebu
fait des poids welters le combat est
programmée le 2 décembre à las palmas
sur les îles canaries
déjà champion de france est détenteur de
la ceinture de l'union européenne le
saint quentinois sera le favori de la
rencontre
mais le boxeur ne veut pas se coller
cette étiquette on les écoute
[Musique]
j'espère en tout cas on continue cet
agenda part du judo le traditionnel
tournoi international de judo de trappes
fêtera ce week-end sa 24e édition en
gymnase paul mallet comme tous les ans
plus de 600 sportifs sont attendus dans
l'enceinte saint-quentinoise pour
participer à l'événement on attend des
judokas de l'île de france mais
également de la france entière est
également des étrangers
si vous êtes intéressé la compétition
débutera le matin à 9 heures il y aura
également du handball
un match capital pour l'équipe senior
féminine de montigny le bretonneux ce
week-end lésigny monteyne reçoivent
harnes dans leur gymnase pierre de
coubertin l'occasion de la 7e journée de
national 2 descendue cette année dans
cette division la smb est pour le moment
encore bien mauvaise posture en
championnat avec un bilan de cinq
défaites en six matches les filles
occupent pour le moment la dernière
place du classement
une victoire pourrait leur allait les
relancer dans cette division en football
le championnat excellence se poursuit à
ce week-end avec la 9e journée lui en
cours saint quentin van dernier du
classement reçoit le 2e le ch ine point
choc des extrêmes du en cours en manque
de points en ce début de saison espère
l'emporter pour viser la montée en fin
d'exercice
si vous voulez les encourager le match
est programmé ce dimanche à 15 heures au
stade maurice baki on termine par le
gros match à ne pas manquer à ce
week-end en rugby plaisir deuxième du
classement de fédérale iii reçoit le
premier ris orangis encore invaincue
cette saison les plaisirs roy doivent
l'emporter pour espérer terminer premier
du classement et ainsi rencontrer une
équipe plus faible en phase de playoffs
dans les tribunes on attend entre 300 et
500 spectateurs pour supporter les jaune
et bleu
c'est la fin de ce soit huit sports
merci d'avoir suivi on se retrouve là
10 prochain pour un nouveau magazine à
10 il a passé une excellente semaine
sportive
[Musique]